thank you so much I know why you're
happy this is the week that Trump found
out that everyone hates him
and I don't mean I don't mean people
like me I mean the people who work for
him Bob Woodward's new book came out or
the excerpts did and it's called all the
president's men think he's an idiot
I mean boy Bob Woodward first Nixon now
he's doing Trump he has brought down
more Republicans than gay sex in public
restaurants but it's been a a real
double whammy for the president because
verse the excerpt came out for the wood
Bert book and then the day after then
anonymous you saw this this anonymous
op-ed was printed in the New York Times
from a very high up White House official
and both the book and the op-eds a
basically the same thing that there was
a resistance from inside the White House
the anonymous authors had many senior
officials are working very hard to
protect America from Trump and Trump
started to suspect something was going
on he went into a cabinet meeting and
they were all wearing [ __ ] hats
everybody wants to know what this
anonymous anonymous a senior official
who wrote in his piece that he or she
finds Trump to be a moral and impulsive
and ill-informed and petty so suspects
include everybody because it's hurt that
everybody in the White House is living
in this bizarro world where they are not
who they say they are and today Melania
said oh I thought I was the only one
faking it you know what she even had to
deny it even asked Melania and she said
no it's not me if I have something to
say I'll write it on my jacket that does
but what Trump is so pissed off what a
turncoat right in his presence a traitor
who would betray the Russians like that
he's pissed off he's he says the New
York Times must turn over turn over and
not turn him over what [ __ ] country
does he think he lives in will be turn
people over for national security
purposes until we catch this guy he says
the threat level is going to Orange
but still white around the eyes you know
it's a warning sign when the president
looks like a warning sign
no one's debating whether he's crazy I'm
still getting over the fact that the
president dyes his hair platinum blonde
and paints his face basketball orange he
sounds like a Drunken looks like a
tequila sunrise after these two things
came out this latest it is very you'd be
hard-pressed to find someone who worked
at an administration who hasn't at some
point called him an idiot or some
version of that idiot [ __ ] that now we
have the defense secretary mattis saying
working in with him like working with
him was like working with a fifth or
sixth grader and Trump he was so mad
when he heard that he spit chocolate
nose
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
let's do it again
oh no we're live but but the paranoia
level in that White House cuz you know
as soon as the anonymous came out then
Trump course detective Trump what 27
high-level people have now denied it
Mike Pence denied it Mike Pompeo Coates
mattis they all said it wasn't me
Lincoln at his team of rivals Trump has
his team of shaggy it wasn't me nobody
remembers that but they're even talking
now but how everyone in the White House
has gonna have to take a lie-detector
test a lie-detector test for the Trump
administration
we don't do that in America we don't
have enough electricity but who wrote a
detective Trump wants to know who is the
author who isn't on is it Kelly is it
Kelly Anne couldn't be Sarah Huckabee
Sanders not like her to lie
Rick Rick Perry said write it I can't
even read it Ben Carson's at anonymous
anonymous do I look Greek but I will
lead the last word on anonymous to the
President himself an anonymous
[Laughter]
build the wall I think the drugs are
still getting in all right